why is a square root called a square
root why does it have the word square in
it also why does a number to the power
to get called a square
I'll explain but pause the video if you
want to try figuring out yourself first
okay here's the answer if you square a
number you basically multiply it by
itself so for example four squared is
four times four which equals 60 now if
you draw this on a graph and put the
first four on the horizontal axis in the
second four on the vertical axis you
actually get a square which has got an
area 60 because it's four times four so
that's where the word square comes from
in squared and square root basically
when you do a square root of a number
let's say 20 you're saying if I have a
square with the area of 20 what's the
length of one of the sides in this case
it's four point four seven blah blah
blah
now some numbers are called perfect
squares which means when you square root
them the answer is a whole number so the
square root of 16 is 4 so 16 is a
perfect square if the number isn't a
perfect square like 20 then the square
root is a decimal like four point four
seven to blah-blah-blah-blah-blah so 20
isn't a perfect square here's another
interesting thing the answer to square
root is always a little imprecise
because there are actually two answers
positive and a negative one so the
square root of 16 is actually both plus
4 and minus 4 this is because minus 4
squared also gives you 16 because it's
minus 4 times minus 4 and a negative
number times a negative number equals a
positive number so you don't know which
one it is
so people normally just take the
positive now this is interesting because
it's also why you can never have the
square root of a negative number is
because nothing times itself makes a
negative number
it's not also like having a square with
a negative area which you can in fact
get if you look at our graph it would
come from 4 times minus 4 or minus 4
times 4 but minus 4 and 4 are different
numbers
so it can't be the answer to a square
root and beyond that when you've got a
number to the path three it's called a
cube because you multiply it by itself
three times extending an air into the
third dimension and the opposite of this
is called the cube root then also if
you've got a number to the path or you
extend it out into the fourth dimension
but this is totally hard to draw or even
imagine so you kind of just have to
trust the maths so this is why it's
called the square root I also looked up
where the word root comes from in square
root and the root of that word is from
the Roman word radix which is also why
the symbol for square root is called a
radical who knew